[Música]
[Aplausos]
el ser humano lleva más de 40 mil años
soplando a través de tubos para hacer
música os imagináis cómo fue la primera
vez que alguien les sonó la flauta que
alguien sopló a través de un hueso y
aquello sonó de hecho en castellano la
expresión elección a la flauta hace
referencia cuando descubrimos algo
fortuitamente cuando hacemos un hallazgo
casual y precisamente de eso quería
hablaros hoy de algunos hallazgos
casuales cerén típicos podríamos decir
que tienen mucho que ver con pitos con
flauta y sobre todo también con un
concepto un concepto que se define más
bien como una pregunta es una pregunta
que es la que abre las puertas de la
creatividad esa pregunta es de cuántas
maneras
hace tiempo que conocí esta flauta este
es el cabal el cabal este en concreto
viene de bulgaria y me encanta porque se
puede tocar de muchas maneras
[Música]
i
entonces hace unos años estaba buscando
un tubo con el cual fabricar me una
flauta y de repente buscando así en tubo
cercano
encontré el tubo del recogedor doméstico
común este fue el primer hecho ser en
típicos vimos que tiene el mismo
diámetro que el de una de mis favoritas
que el cava el vulgar con lo cual
ya deducimos que simplemente este palo
material está tan humilde podemos
hacerlo sonar de muchas maneras de hecho
de las mismas maneras con las cuales
suena el cabal soplando en el borde
[Música]
también podemos hacerlo sonar metiéndolo
entre los dientes
siempre buscando de cuántas maneras de
cuántas maneras podemos ver que también
se puede tocar como una trompeta
[Música]
y claro aquí únicamente lo que faltaba
eran los agujeros así que simplemente
realizando orificios en el palo en el
tubo del recogedor en el mismo sitio que
nuestra flauta aquí se produjo el
segundo hallazgo cerén típico
recordáis el sonido de la flauta
original
[Música]
[Aplausos]
uno descubre esto se le vienen muchas
cosas a la cabeza yo esperaba que sonara
más o menos igual que los de madera de
luthier el otro es de plástico con esto
no quiero decir que tiene que comprar
instrumentos buenos de luthier de hecho
me vayan a dañar a todos los líderes del
mundo a buscarme un instrumento bueno te
ayuda a alcanzar la excelencia pero este
este tiene sonido mucho más limpios y
recogidos eso está claro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
con el proyecto vibrato llevamos más de
13 años dando talleres de construcción
de instrumentos haciendo conciertos en
todas partes del mundo con él con el
objetivo de transmitir el amor por la
música el interés por los instrumentos
por el folclore así como el respeto por
el medio ambiente fomentar la
creatividad y el tercer hallazgo ser en
típico pues fue precisamente eso como en
instrumentos como éste hallamos todo ese
concepto como rompe barreras y
directamente a la gente le llega la idea
de lo que es no pues una flauta es un
tubo y así con todas las ideas vivimos
en un mundo que es prácticamente de una
especialización ya extrema no hay una
carrera concreta para cada segmento del
conocimiento hay una herramienta
específica para cada micro tarea hay un
procedimiento para cada fin es un poco
lo que hablan los compañeros en las
charlas anteriores y a veces se me
olvida tener esa mirada amplia no que
sobrepasen nuestras barreras de nuestra
especialización y buscar las soluciones
pues prácticamente ahí donde
donde otros desechan donde otros ven
basura o ven algo que tirar y así como
podemos encontrar soluciones increíbles
en materiales de desecho también lo
podemos encontrar en ideas que
desechamos en ideas o comportamientos
que desechamos de pequeño cuando
empezaba a tocar el clarinete
con 8 añitos cometía dos errores que me
impedían avanzar
uno de ellos era que cerraba muchísimo
la garganta en vez de conseguir la
presión digamos dándole más fuerza al
grifo yo lo hacía poniendo el dedo en la
punta de la goma no como cuando estás
regando y otro error que tenía era que
ponía mucho la lengua aquí en la
lengüeta utilizaba demasiado la lengua
entonces en vez es una el clarinete como
más o menos así
mencionaba de esta manera
lo cual nos gustaba mucho en mi
alrededor y tampoco a mí no pero
llevando esos dos errores al extremo
máximo sea cerrando lo máximo que puede
en la garganta y poniendo la lengua lo
máximo posible
produjo un hallazgo científico también
[Música]
y ese fue gracia
ese fue un sonido que encontré de
casualidad eso basado en los errores y
que luego ya más tarde me enteré que eso
tenía un nombre que era muy difícil de
hacer lo primero que me salió pero lo
difícil lo otro no está bien pero
precisamente por eso a veces cuando le
enseñamos a los niños cuando simón o eso
no es así de esta manera deja lo
experimente por esa manera que agote
todas las posibilidades que veas de
cuántas maneras puede llegar por ahí y
luego experimentamos la buena no por
ejemplo todo el mundo sabe la flauta
travesera conocéis no un instrumento muy
muy típico muy común tiene aquí un
agujero por el cual se sopla y suena tu
toca
[Música]
pero dándole vuelta al instrumento y
viendo ahora de cuántas maneras aquí un
agujero pero aquí hay otro todos los
agujeros tienen derecho a ser tocado no
no hay café
hay que hacerlo todo por el agujero que
nos mandan entonces
pero
[Música]
esto entraña un mundo de posibilidades
de hecho imaginaros ahora podrían tocar
los dos personas a la vez y producir un
ahorro en flauta significativo que
también es muy muy ecológico y muy
respetuoso de hecho ya hay por ahí quien
lo ha hecho buscar por ahí luego tuvo a
flauta sola what for one fruit y veréis
no hay muchos muchos ejemplos de los
cuales podemos inspirarnos
para despedirme os voy a invitar a
probar un pequeño experimento sabéis que
cada vez que vamos a los hoteles tenemos
estos botecitos de champús seguramente
muchos de vosotros estarán alojando en
algún hotel o si no lo harán en el
futuro pues bien estos botecitos según
el hotel en el que tú te alojes pues si
es un hotel caro te dan mucho champú y
cuando se vacía da una nota grave se
llama
este es más caro
es ordenar un hotel mediano
tenemos un pequeño hotel de carretera
[Música]
pues bien esto tan simple que puede
parecer una flauta de una sola nota lo
tocan los pigmeos de centroáfrica y yo
lo que hacen no es de bote de champú es
de otro material vegetal lo que hacen es
que tocan una nota
y en vez de tocar torno a la misma nota
bueno parece un camión marcha atrás y no
sería tan rico su folclore pues en vez
de eso lo que hacen es que van
respondiendo al botecito
[Música]
entonces os invito creo que alguno de
vosotros tenéis protegido disculpando he
podido conseguir botes para todos así lo
más difícil prepararme esta charla
si queremos invito a un último una
pequeña improvisación con vuestros con
vuestros botecitos simplemente soplando
en el borde del tubo y que sirva como
ejemplo de algo tan tan pequeño y tan
insignificante que viendo de cuántas
maneras podemos darle la vuelta y
extraer pues grandes hallazgos a veces
incluso ser en típico
naturalmente
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]